c'est le moyen de transport phare du
déconfinement le vélo connaît un franc
succès dans ce magasin le constat est
clair une augmentation de près de 30%
des ventes depuis le 11 mai leur envie
de s'évader de prendre un petit peu
d'aller voir un petit peu la nature mais
aussi l'envié de se déplacer autrement
peut-être ne pas prendre les transports
en commun voilà de changer un petit peu
de mode mode de mode de vie de mode de
déplacement on voulait les clients
achètent aussi des vélos assez
polyvalent pour justement faire un petit
peu tout une pratique loisir une
pratique vélo taf
même phénomène dans cet autre enseigne
une croissance de 60% du chiffre
d'affaires depuis le déconfinement un
vélo sur deux vendus et électriques
plusieurs utilisations les déplacements
pour aller au travail faire ses courses
ou se balader
aujourd'hui on commence à avoir un peu
de mal à avoir certaines certaine à pro
il va y avoir les certains fabricants
nous annonce quand même un trou sur la
fin de l'année sur le vélo aujourd'hui
on a aussi le flux du coup de monter les
vélos qui sont déjà en magasin et dès
qu'un vélo est monté il part dans la
semaine dans la région il ya plein de
bois il ya des pistes cyclables qui sont
chantier plus de 200 kilomètres de
pistes cyclables très très privilégiés
protégés
je serai le rire du vélo en famille donc
assez naturellement
eh bien les ventes de vélos suivent les
infrastructures cyclables suivent le
mouvement les intercommunalités s'engage
notamment dans cette voie c'est le cas
de l'agglomération versailles grand parc
et le développement d'un réseau de 72 km
de pistes cyclables les associations
vélo sur le territoire qui prennent de
plus en plus d'envergure avec qui on
essaye de de discuter au quotidien pour
faire avancer tous ces sujets mais avec
la crise est venue accélérer ce
mouvement
autre exemple d'engagement le 27 mai
dernier la région ile de france a voté
une enveloppe de 300 millions d'euros
objectif développer le rer vélo pour
relier paris à la grande couronne via un
réseau de pistes cyclables